hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and more specifically welcome
to the hunter hunter Ark review where
today we are going to be tackling our
first truly grand piece of storytelling
in the series with the york-new city our
york-new city is the fourth arc in the
series consisting of a mighty 56 manga
chapters as well as 26 episodes of the
original 1999 anime adaptation and 22
episodes of the 2011 series so as stated
before we do have quite the lengthy
piece of story here with this arc and
the first true display of the kind of
storytelling takashi would elect to
engage in going forward so york-new city
is a groundbreaking arc in the series
for many reasons the first of which is
that it actively makes a decision to
remove the focus on our main protagonist
gone and instead promote karapa kibrit
flee into this lead role of course that
doesn't mean that gun is relegated to
the background he is actually quite a
huge part in this arc but the driving
force is undeniably karateka and going
through the series the first time around
I wasn't quite sure how to feel about
this because of the four protagonists
introduced during the hunter exam our
crop ago was easily my least favorite
however york-new City took this
character and made him quite possibly
the most compelling force in the series
to this point and possibly even beyond
and I think a lot of that comes from two
very big narrative strengths one of
which is the classic revenge story
motive it's just so easy for readers and
watches or at the very least me to get
on board with revenge because it's
always about an underdog taking on
powers far greater than them and the
satisfaction of seeing them succeed or
the tragedy that the corruption of
revenge inevitably brings the other very
well-done aspect of crop occur though is
portraying him as a natural genius which
is usually great because when done
correctly these characters can very
effectively guide you through the most
interesting and well-thought-out
scenarios
although I say when done correctly
because this idea can very very easily
fall apart and become annoyingly
pretentious so it is a very difficult
thing to pull off really because to have
a genius-level character you as an
author really need to put some serious
thought into it and to be perfectly
honest a lot of authors who tackle these
kind of characters just don't have the
mental commitment to do so but in the
case of crop Rika it's a genuinely
compelling feature and watching him
think and act makes me personally feel
smarter although that feeling is a
complete and utter lie the orc new city
is much more complex than just one
protagonist sir because as mentioned
before we do also have a narrative
thread going with Gong Kilwa and even
the audio but there is
a massive group of individuals who take
center stage during the arc which have a
phantom troop now at first it's very
easy to classify these figures as
antagonists of the arc the figures of
evil that crop oka is hunting down but
as time goes on in york new city that
perception becomes wildly skewed and i
would actually go so far as to say that
this cohort becomes another group of
protagonists and it's because we end up
spending an awful lot of time with them
almost as much as with karateka go on
and kill allah and we really get to know
them personally well a select few of
them anyway but that goes a long way
towards humanizing them which is crazy
because they are introduced as brutal
killers who Massacre the Mafia auction
as well as murder a few characters that
we went nice and familiar with at the
time but over the course of this arc
many of these characters have very
empathetic moments for example after the
death of boob again we get some great
insight into the sadness and rage felt
by Nobunaga even though nothing is
explicitly stated but it conveys a sense
of how deep their camaraderie was and in
regards to Nobunaga specifically this
character is given even further depth by
showing his sense of humor generally in
regards to anything involving go on and
kill her but another fantastic example
is Paco Noda who provides the emotional
climax of your pew city with her
sacrifice to provide the troupe with
valuable information as well to save the
life of crow lo watching her forego her
life and shoot the rest of the trip with
the memory bomb bullets is such an
astonishingly heartbreaking moment
because I never could have imagined
myself feeling anything for these
characters at the beginning of the arc
they were just that well done and there
you go there really is a kind of twisted
argument to be made the karateka almost
comes off as more of the villain in
york-new city than the phantom trip due
because from that perspective this is a
story of a group being hunted and killed
by an unseen force and have to scramble
to come together to defeat this threat I
mean there is a lot of context you need
to ignore to see it that way such as
their penchant for murder which is an
ongoing theme that gets brought up a lot
crop occur even questions will gain and
Crow law on the matter and gon bring it
up in the presence of Nobunaga and every
time the trooper faced with this
question they don't have a convincing
answer for themselves it's just what
they do
meanwhile though karateka ends up coming
off is quite villainous because by the
end of york new city kind of loses
himself succumbing to rage and revenge
so much so that his plan in the end
isn't even particularly successful I
mean yeah he prevents crawler from
contacting the troupe and using nen but
by then he had realized that the troupe
are not a group so easily defeated by
the loss of their leader and they are in
fact significantly more human and in
way they work to ensure the survival of
the spider as a whole so in the end
Crockett didn't really succeed in
accomplishing a whole lot and his
ultimate revenge plan was effectively
defeated by the strong bond of the
phantom true which is a really weird way
to think about the arc but it's true
neither party really came out of this
conflict as Victor and as a result the
conclusion of York New City leaves this
weird aftertaste because there's no real
satisfaction from its events it's quite
a realistic depiction of revenge being
taken against figures that are
inherently human so there's all sorts of
complex emotions playing about and does
it often isn't reality it just kind of
ends in a big unsatisfying mess but no
one really predicted an enjoyable mess
though a very enjoyable mess and you
know in general york-new represents a
pretty big tonal shift in hunter hunter
which colors it a shade darker through a
wide variety of factors one of which is
cropping as seemingly relentless quest
for revenge and the kind of actions that
he was willing to take to ensure it me
for example when he and melody first
started speaking she judged that he
would be more than willing to kill her
if she was in any way threatening to his
cause but it's not just that the world
itself becomes a much darker place
through the exploration of the various
mafia factions as well as the phantom
troupe and we even get some interaction
with the professional assassination
world of the zoldak family it really is
a crash course of the underbelly of the
hunt hunt diverse and there's a lot of
really almost sickening stuff at play
that just gets taken for granted like
the whole concept of flesh collectors
one of which is personified by the most
innocent-looking character in the entire
arc and they almost rot and it really is
such a striking juxtaposition that a
girl like her would be so heavily
involved in this trade and just think
that it's a completely normal hobby
speaking of neon though she along with
crow lo and Karaka bring one of the most
interesting features of york-new City
which is the proper introduction of
known specialists and the further
deepening of just how insane this art
form can get each of the three
specialist abilities we get to explore
in this arc are extremely fascinating
but I find myself most taken in by neons
of the Ghost Rider ability which
accurately predicts portions of
individuals with simple information but
it is restricted by the amount of time
at comparing to the future as well as
delivering it through cryptic poetry
lovely ghost writer just adds a
fantastic element of intrigue to the arc
especially after krola requires it by
his own specialist ability bandit secret
which is more terrifying than anything
and set scroll o up to be an incredible
powerhouse figure and finally cropping
as Emperor time was and still is the
epitome of fantastically driven men use
it immediately l
Crockett to the status of one of the
best known uses in series but at the
same time it also goes to serve to
solidify a lot of new knowledge by
providing the calculations of how under
the conditions of Emperor time grandpa
cook can maximize the efficiency of each
of his own non-natural main areas plus
it also results in the great versatility
of his trained abilities and every east
of those put just amazing and a good
highlight in regards to that would be
the fight against du virgeen which was
such a brilliant display of dominance
from karateka as almost battles in
hunter hunter actually i mean not from
crop occur personally but when you think
about it most fights in hunter hunter
I'm very very one-sided yet they're so
compelling something interesting in that
but I love how Joshi still makes these
combat focus segments a true pleasure to
experience even though the victor is
often clear right from the beginning and
that's a very intriguing talent because
you'd suspect that the best possible
action sequences would come from even
match ups but nope this series goes on
to prove that very wrong with that said
there was a slightly more even matchup
that I would like to highlight between
Crowe Lo and the Seoul dings this was
such a great spectacle to see and it
made me want ever so much more from
these three figures involved and the
best part about it was that it was such
an intriguing mental battle more than
anything I mean the physical action was
great but the meat of it was really
seeing the thoughts of Zeno and krohler
and how a fight needs to be fought once
mentally before it can actually be
implemented physically and now one of
the last things I'd like to touch on is
that York New City is a bit of a bizarre
arc narrative Lee because it spends an
awful lot of time actually setting up
the arc immediately after it being greed
island so almost everything to do with
gone and kill WA is working towards that
end and in fact your new city actually
begins with gon and killua on the hunt
for the Green Island game and then it
slowly morphs into the actual York new
city off and a lot of this is great
because it means that these two arcs
flow very naturally together although I
will say that it was definitely my least
favorite stuff about York new city
especially when we go into a ton of
depth about the world of auctions and
their various processes so for example
there is an entire chapter focused on
the wooden vault and the various ways to
potentially counterfeit it as well as
the concept of deflated and auctions who
actively worked to drive prices down and
it's all very legitimately fascinating
information but it just feels so out of
place within the greater context of the
arc and yes I know that the wooden vault
discussion does come back to help gone
and kilowatt escaped once from Nobunaga
Hoadley enough but a whole chapter that
describes a niche faction of options and
reads almost like a textbook was just
kind of weird
interesting
but weird and it kind of broke the flow
of the story and I will stand by the
fact that not enough of it comes back
into the story to justify taking an
entire chapter just to describe it
I feel like Takashi was just heavily
invested in auctions and the concept of
auctions at the time and so he put that
passion into his work and well he got a
bit carried away which certainly does
happen in the future of the series as
well and finally I just like to leave
you all with one very interesting line
from gone
with some great fall shadowing in which
he comes to accept his own fairly
selfish ways of operating and in fact he
says to Kilwa I'm the one who's reckless
you have to keep me in line and Wow
that's quite something to read in
retrospect I mean I highly doubt that
Takashi had guns eventual story planned
out at this point to the series but
looking back on it it's safe to say the
Kilowog kind failed in that regard but
that's very much york-new City a
fantastic first offering of a grand Iraq
with far more intricate storytelling and
a shifting focus from the general idea
of Shonen which infinitely expands the
world and provides a very gripping
narrative I mean so long as we're not
being given a lecture of the technical
implementation of an auction but that
pretty much does it for the York New
City arc if you enjoyed this video and
the content this channel produced in
general then please do consider donating
to the New World review patreon because
the support of all of you amazing people
is what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel and
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun at any time and please do
head over to my discord server where a
wide array of Chenal eerie takes place
on a daily basis and finally please do
comment with your thoughts on the york
new city arc this has been the new world
review and i'll see you next time
[Music]
what's your favorite game of all time
you know I think I'd have to go with a
Diablo - I've played a lot of games in
my day but I don't think I've ever gone
back to something as consistently as
Diablo - I mean back in high school I'd
replay this thing at least once a year
and spend at least two solid weeks
heavily invested into it and even now I
go back to whatever a couple of years
which i think is insane because it's
like 20 years old but it's just such a
good game